[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Andra how
can we
help Hi how are you good Kendra what's
going
on um I just got married about a month
ago oh that's exciting way to
go thank you um we combined all of our
finances and we had a plan to pay for
the wedding and that plan did not go
according
so we ended up going into a bit of debt
on top of some pre-existing debt so now
we're just kind of looking for advice as
newly WS to what happen start off right
and get out of this what
happened um we were living with family
so we were able to set the money aside
we weren't really paying rent and that
plan faded and we ended up moving out
and getting into a house which of course
in Denver the rent is Skyrock rocketing
wait y'all went y'all up and bought a
house uh we actually rent a house oh
rent a house okay okay yeah so how much
that kind of took our wedding budget
away from us but we weren't really
willing to compromise on the wedding
which was not a good financial decision
by any means so we went into debt oh how
much money did you loan did you get take
a loan out for this
wedding we took about 32,000 well 3
$332,000 for a
wedding yeah please tell me it's not on
like credit cards how did you pay for it
we did we started with credit cards and
I did have some savings so we paid for
part of it as we went but uh 32,000 is
actually on personal loan wow what did
you spend that on I'm just curious
because I've been married a long time
and I had no idea weddings I know that
they can be outrageous but what did you
spend that money I got to
know uh the venue by itself was about
7500 and that's no service or anything
just the building basically okay um
photographers videographers football
everything I wondered if you just rented
a shrimp boat to bring the shrimp in for
the reception it was so expensive my
gosh so you had you had some money you
had some money that you paid cash with
and this is the 32,000 wasn't the
overall cost of the wedding that was the
overage that you went into debt for
correct
so I mean I think our wedding was
budgeted at right about 35 total so you
didn't spend any of your real money
credit card debt well we had some
pre-existing credit card debt so we were
paying for stuff kind of as we went and
paying that off as we booked vendors but
okay well so much for the uh so much for
the honeymoon period oh gosh because now
you all going to have to bust it to pay
this off um yeah no kidding yeah okay
there's a big flag here for me like
there's something that's glaringly like
like glaring its red light and it's the
fact that early on you guys were hit
with a a fork in the road like do we
lower do we lower our budget and get
what we can afford or do we just say the
heck with it and you know put the pedal
to the metal and go into debt right um
so I'm worried because and and I'm
worried too that there was credit cards
involved and all this stuff so you guys
have a a a mental mind shift that must
happen um do you see what I'm saying
that's the bigger impulsive in our
spending yeah so that's that's almost a
bigger deal for me in this moment than
the debt is you guys looking at each
other and going okay how do we want to
live our life from now on like what type
of people are we going to be uh what
type of adults are we going to be when
it comes to money are we going and this
is a conversation this is the next date
night are we going to be the type of
people that we see um a vacation we want
and we see a TV or a car that we want
and we go you know what we can afford to
just take out the payments I mean we'll
just pay it off for or are you going to
be the type of people that go you know
what from here on out drawing a Line in
the Sand we don't borrow money and
that's first and foremost you guys both
need to look at each other and say are
we going to be the people who decide
that we don't borrow money
anymore yep we have had that talk and
what's the
answer I think we're on the same page um
just from like watching the videos and
stuff
online I just I got to tell you you
think you're on the same page on the
same page what she she is on the page
ready to jump into it oh I know you are
I think you're on the page I don't think
he's anywhere near the book he's in a
MAG he's in a a magazine he's in a Truck
magazine where is he is that true he's
not that he's not that okay good good so
what's what's your so real quick what's
your combined what's the debt not just
the wedding the total debt and then what
are your combined
incomes yep so total debt I calculated
it about we're just under 90 I think
it's like 88,000 okay and can you break
down the type of debt com sure um we
have two vehicle loans those are both
about 16,000 each um I have student
loans which luckily is only about 8,000
could be much worse um and then credit
cards combined we have about 16,000 left
and then the personal loan for 32 on the
wedding who gave you that
money uh just like Sofi loan or
something okay I you personal loan I
misunderstood okay and what's your
combined
income right now I'm estimating about
130 his kind of various so so you guys
can do this but you got to get dramatic
with it you got to get real dramatic U
so so you called we we what was your
question for us did we did we answer
what you wanted us to answer answer did
you ask it what what what can we do here
really just kind of looking for advice
on where to start all right so I'd start
with the
cars do you have any equity in those
cars not really you're upside
down I don't think we're really upside
down but we'd probably break even or
be slightly upside down like $1,000 or
$2,000 not anything
major you know so first first and
foremost debt snowball like Ken is Right
I'd be looking at these cars but first
we're listing them smallest to largest
so the the $88,000 student loan
technically is first in your snowball
however well actually that's not true
your credit cards what's the lowest I'm
I'm guessing it's not just one credit
card for 16,000 right yeah yeah there's
um one is about a $10,000 balance but
then the rest of them are all pretty
small okay so we'll we'll list them
smallest to largest and knock out the
smallest ones first so that that's
that's the overarching game plan of this
and that's how you're going to feel
motivated to keep going so tonight you
guys get off the phone and go okay let's
put these things and Order smallest to
largest that's thing one then next do
you guys have a budget are you on a
budget at
all um I've kind of just like started
writing stuff down all right well we're
going to make sure that you have we're
going to make sure you have every dollar
which is the world's best budgeting app
on the planet it's going to help you
guys get control you're both going to be
able to see it it's going to be on both
of your mobile devices on both of your
laptop computers so you can see it
you're going to be able to see your
money each day in real time what's going
on with your money so uh make sure that
Austin picks up to get you that and
those are the two keys find out what's
going on with your money and find as
much margin as possible so you can throw
that at the smallest debt and that's how
you work through this debt snowball you
guys can be clear of this in 12 in 24
months